desde que era muy pequeño solía
provocarle insomnio a mi mamá mi mamá no
podía dormir durante las noches porque
ya estaba a su lado
hablándole por horas y horas sobre
cuántos satélites tenía júpiter o quién
nuevo descubrimiento nos traía el mundo
de las ciencias
no teníamos internet en casa hasta que
cumplió 11 años sin embargo mucho antes
teníamos una colección enorme de
enciclopedias y libros que venían en
conjunto con el periódico recuerdo pasar
horas devorando esos libros dibujando
cohetes planetas cometas
también observando el cielo recuerdo y
cada noche me acostaba en el patio y
pasaba también horas solamente mirando y
apreciando todo lo que tenía el cielo
por ofrecer
desde muy chico tuve lo porque la
oportunidad de entrar me en lo que ahora
mismo considero mi pasión
la pequeña y remota posibilidad de
convertirme en un astronauta
esta carrera por lograr mis sueños me ha
llevado a través de muchísimas aventuras
muchísimas experiencias en las que he
aprendido lecciones de vida invaluables
y valoro mucho la oportunidad que tengo
de poder compartir estas experiencias
con otros jóvenes de poder de alguna
manera inspirar a otros y poder
demostrar lo que es capaz de hacer con
relativamente poco dinero pero con mucho
esfuerzo y dedicación
es posible es evidente de hecho pensar
en que llevamos la astronomía pero mi
carrera no empieza ahí es de hecho muy
difícil hacer sabiendo que es lo que uno
quiere lograr cuando sea grande de hecho
nos ocurre muy frecuentemente que al
terminar el colegio empezar la facultad
en esa etapa de nuestras vidas nos
encontramos con un dilema a donde
dirigimos nuestras vidas qué es lo que
vamos a realizar los siguientes años
esta es una respuesta que nos llega con
la experiencia ya que 18 años tuve la
oportunidad poder experimentar en
distintas áreas y poder descubrir muchos
campos que también me interesan
tuve la oportunidad de participar en
muchos eventos de dibujos cursos de
verano talleres también en deportes
fútbol natación atletismo
me probé en estas áreas porque el
colegio definitivamente no sentía que
podía satisfacer toda la curiosidad que
sentía nunca fue suficiente siempre
quería probar cosas nuevas por mi cuenta
y tengo la oportunidad de tener una
familia que siempre me apoyo que siempre
me acompañó en todos estas nuevas
experimentos que ya estaba haciendo con
mi cuenta
una nunca sabe lo que es capaz de lograr
hasta que lo intenta esta es una frase
que puede sonar muy cliché muy genérica
leemos por todas partes de verdad famoso
sin embargo es posible convertir esta
frase en algo muy tangible y muy real
para cualquier persona y les voy a
contar una historia que lo demuestra
cuando yo tenía 15 años pertenecía a que
el grupo de la clase es que se portaba
mal verdad tenía notas promedio no sea
de hecho yo no participaba en algo fuera
del colegio solamente he estudiado salía
con amigos nada fuera de lo normal
sin embargo un día llega un profesor de
ciencias a clases con un afiche
publicitario de una competencia muy
particular era la olimpiada
latinoamericana de astronomía y
astronáutica
esta competencia consistía en una prueba
teórica individual que abarca campos de
trigonometría esférica astrofísica
astrometría y muchos conceptos teóricos
también está la prueba observacional
donde teníamos que ubicar señalar
estrellas nombrarlas utilizando el láser
y telescopios de diferentes tipos
también consistían en esta prueba que es
mi favorita la prueba de cohetería se
puede apreciar es mucho que estoy
disfrutando viendo ese cohete lanzándose
que consiste en el diseño construcción y
lanzamiento de cohetes que funcionan con
agua y aire comprimido
por si esto no fuera suficiente yo sabía
que al adentrarme en esta competencia
iba a estar compitiendo con cientos de
otros jóvenes de todo el país ya
campeones de física de matemática los
mismos ex participantes de la misma
competencia
en definitiva me estaba entrando en un
campo desconocido y en aquello que no
tenía experiencia
todo parecía jugar me en contra
sin embargo contra todo pronóstico aquel
año
logró pasar por los distintos procesos
selectivos en el que empezamos unos
cuantos cientos y terminamos los mejores
cinco para participar en la olimpiada
latinoamericana que ese año fue en
argentina en la que finalmente logró
poner mi primera medalla internacional
ese año aprendí en realidad mucho más
que conceptos teóricos o fórmulas empecé
a descubrirme a mí mismo me encontraba
estudiando mucho más de lo que nunca
había estudiado y sin darme cuenta
empecé a entender la belleza de las
matemáticas y entender ligeramente mejor
cómo funciona el mundo que nos rodea
algo también muy importante que aprendí
es que las notas no definen nuestra
capacidad de desenvolvernos en ningún
ámbito y mucho menos la opinión de los
demás
luego de esa competencia mi vida pasó a
cambiar exponencialmente me empecé a
involucrar en eventos me podía aprender
más y más
poco después de esa olimpiada participé
en un curso de cinco días en la que con
unos amigos
creamos una página web en las que
recolectamos información sobre
actividades y oportunidades académicas
para jóvenes paraguayos que buscan
mejorar su formación
también fui seleccionado por una para
una beca de la embajada de eeuu para
poder estudiar inglés durante dos años y
volvió a participar en la limpiadora de
astronomía en la que junto con un amigo
logramos obtener las primeras dos
medallas de oro para nuestro país en una
competencia internacional de ámbito
académico
luego de graduarme en el programa access
que es el programa de estudios del
idioma inglés tuve la oportunidad de
poder expandir mis horizontes y
adentrarme en un nuevo desafío
descubrí la oportunidad de poder
participar en un evento llamado space
camp descubrí que existían becas
disponibles para participar en este
curso que se daba a cabo en un complejo
de la nasa en eeuu y tenía la
oportunidad de poder pasar por diversos
desafíos en la que estaría puesto a
prueba de una manera similar en la que
entrenan los astronautas pero obviamente
de una manera en la que jóvenes de mi
edad pueden poder participar
era la oportunidad de mi vida
definitivamente estaba seguro de que
tenía que probar tenía que intentar como
sea tenía entendido que iba a ser muy
difícil sin embargo me postulé
una tarde del 13 de marzo de 2018 me
llega una carta una notificación al
correo era la carta de admisión recuerdo
muy bien que estaba en el odontólogo y
tenía la boca cerrada por lo que ni
siquiera poder reaccionar a esta está el
nombre de notificación que tenía siempre
anhelé la posibilidad de poder conocer
la nasa y tenía la oportunidad de ahí en
frente mío sin embargo aún tenía una
dificultad que sobrepasar no tenía
dinero para poder cubrir mi pasaje de
avión y para cubrir otros gastos extras
que también involucraba mi participación
cuatro días después escribí un post en
mi facebook comentando acerca de la
situación también poniendo el número mi
número de celular y el número de cuenta
bancaria de mi hermano
esa noche dormí sin prestar mucha
atención al mente lula al día siguiente
tenía un examen importante a la mañana
por lo que tampoco me fijo en las
notificaciones durante las dos horas que
dura ese examen mi celular vibra
cuando finalmente terminó el salgo de
clases logró atender una llamada de un
número desconocido y me dice lo
siguiente muy buenas tardes usted es
sebastián núñez si así es con quien
hablo le estamos llamando desde la radio
y estamos muy orgullosos de poder
anunciar te de que ya tenés los pasajes
y los viáticos cubiertos ya no tienes
nada de qué preocuparse
había sido y para mi sorpresa mi post se
había vuelto viral empecé a aparecer en
programas de radio de televisión en los
en las instituciones más importantes de
mi país empecé a recibir mensajes de
cientos de paraguayos no sólo en
paraguay sino en todo el mundo
expresando su felicidad y su orgullo de
saber que un paraguayo estaría
representando les en la nasa pero es un
país pequeño y estas cosas no suceden
muy a menudo
a pesar de haber resuelto el problema de
mis pasajes de avión aún tenía que poder
cubrir otros gastos relacionados al
viaje
calculé que necesitaría aproximadamente
600 dólares para poder cubrir todos mis
gastos en ese periodo lo cual estaba muy
lejano de lo que yo podía pagar al cabo
de dos meses había recaudado ya dos mil
dólares recibí muchísimas ayudas
muchísimos paraguayos e incluso
extranjeros habían acogido me ayudó
en huntsville que es la ciudad dónde se
lleva a cabo el evento tuve la
oportunidad de recibir ofertas para
quedarme en los hogares de dos familias
paraguayas en la paraguaya y otra
americana en la cual estoy muy
agradecido con ellos también conocí a un
paraguayo que se encontraba trabajando
en la nasa y conversamos mucho y me
ayudó en muchos aspectos de cómo yo
podría lograr algo similar también
esta chica
se llama maria antonia
voy a cambiar un poco de tema para
hablar acerca de una de un aspecto de
nuestra juventud que considero muy
importante
nosotros la juventud latinoamericana
tenemos muchos más talentos que
oportunidades
sin embargo cada día se presentan más
oportunidades más programas de décadas y
más oportunidades en las que podemos
participar y aprender muchas cosas y es
muy importante determinarse a participar
y aprender en todas y cada una de ellas
en enero de este año participé en un
campamento de liderazgos donde pude
conocer a maría antonia esta es una
chica que vive en una favela en salvador
bahía que al recibir la carta admisión a
dicho programa también se encontró con
la misma dificultad que yo no sabía cómo
podía financiar los pasajes y también su
estadía en sao paulo entonces ella
utilizó su pasión y su habilidad de
poder crear diseños y lujos entonces
empezó a diseñar sus propias remeras ya
vender online de esa manera pudo
financiar sus pasajes y participar en
este evento
también en el mismo evento donde conocí
a mis amigos donde creamos la página web
de conocían la talla ella es una chica
de paraguay del interior que había
recibido la admisión para participar en
dicho curso sin embargo no contaba con
los fondos ni tampoco con el permiso de
sus padres para poder participar
entonces hizo algo muy particular ahorro
durante semanas y las noches antes del
primer día del evento se escapa de su
casa toma un bus y participa en dicho
evento
al volver a su casa ella crea el primer
club de astronomía de su ciudad donde
lidera y organiza eventos científicos
campamentos conferencias de temas
espaciales y observaciones astronómicas
hoy en día se está preparando para poder
viajar a rusia a estudiar físicamente
mediante una beca completa
maría antonia y ataxia representan
actitudes que todos los jóvenes
deberíamos replicar latinoamérica
representa una de las regiones más
jóvenes del mundo y nuestra generación
representa aproximadamente un tercio de
toda esta población
todos tenemos el futuro de latinoamérica
nuestras manos pero como podemos
realmente ofrecer este cambio como
podemos accionar y de alguna manera
contribuir a un futuro mejor para
latinoamérica
lo podemos lograr actuando localmente y
desde nuestras posibilidades en mi caso
yo suelo participar en eventos donde
puedo compartir mis experiencias poder
enseñar para las olimpiadas
en el colegio donde estoy también
creamos un club de astronomía en este
club gastronomía podemos estudiar para
las olimpiadas convencí a muchos de
poder participar y involucrarse en otros
eventos
el camino para conseguir y luchar por
tus sueños realidad va mucho más allá
que simplemente luchar por tus objetivos
personales se trata de ayudar a los
demás se trata de dar una mano se trata
de convertirse en la que el tutor o
mentor que uno siempre necesito
en aquel campamento de libras o que
participe en sao paulo todos los jóvenes
que estábamos participamos en una
actividad llamada cena con los
emprendedores en aquella cena tuvimos la
oportunidad de recibir una visita de
tres emprendedores sociales brasileños
vito uno de ellos con los que estaba
hablando
se me presta mucha atención lo de que yo
le haya hecho un comentario le había
comentado que ya veces me siento un poco
solo tengo muchos amigos sin embargo
cada grupo es diferente nunca o casi
nunca puedo ser 100% yo
conversaciones sobre cómo cambiará el
mundo cómo seguir tus sueños o cómo
crear proyectos sociales no se dan muy a
menudo e incluso en mi familia a la cual
amo mucho y siempre me apoya siempre
también me suelen decir que debo
enfocarme más en mis estudios y
obligaciones personales antes que en
proyectos y actividades extras las
cuales tanto presento frecuentó
visto muy sabiamente me dice quiero que
mires a tus alrededores observas las
personas en esta sala y me digas 77
seguí sintiendo solo
y terminamos esa conversación abrazados
y yo llorando porque literalmente no
pude aguantar la emoción de poder sentir
una conexión tan profunda y tan grande
con estas otras personas las que había
conocido unos días atrás personas de
diferentes países con diferentes
historias diferentes lenguas personas
que viven muy lejos de mi hogar
descubrí que mi propósito de mi pasión
no solamente es la de ser astronauta
sino que es la de ayudar a ayudar a los
demás a cumplir sus sueños también mi
historia no es excepcional yo creo que
todos tenemos una pasión dentro nuestra
esperando ser descubiertas todos tenemos
una llama dentro de nuestro esperando
ser encendida para toda la eternidad
ningún sueño es demasiado grande es
normal considerar el hecho de ser
astronauta como algo imposible algo
inalcanzable algo de lo que uno crece
madura y supera sin embargo luego de
tantos años yo continúo pensando
exactamente igual y cada día estoy más
seguro y más determinado a poder
lograrlo
nosotros somos la generación martes
porque la persona en pisar ese planeta
por primera vez se encuentra viva y en
nuestra generación
podría ser algunos de ustedes podría ser
yo podría ser cualquiera pero cualquiera
que ya se esté preparando desde ahora
porque quiero hacerles una pregunta
quiero que todos se pregunten
en que están invirtiendo su tiempo para
que se están preparando
y a quién están ayudando
muchas gracias